And with that notation now in our hands, let's return to the discussion
of classical information and probabilistic states, in particular.
And let's consider what happens
when we measure a system while it's in some probabilistic state.
We might not ordinarily
refer to a measurement or the act of measuring
something in a classical setting, but the term makes sense.
In essence, when we talk
about measuring the system X in this context, we just mean that we look at it and we recognize whatever state it's in.
Of course, when we look at the system, we don't see a probabilistic state, we see a classical state,
and the particular
classical state that we see is one that we can
imagine is chosen randomly according to the probabilities.
Now, you might object on
philosophical grounds to the idea that the classical state we see is somehow chosen at random
at the moment that we measure or we look at the system, the system simply was in some particular
classical state all along
and we just happen to have
learned what the state was, but for the sake of thinking about the mathematical
framework we're working with,
it's okay to think about it this way and doing so will allow us to draw a parallel with
quantum information a little bit later.
Let's suppose that the
classical state that we see is the classical state a, which could be any state in our set sigma.
This changes the probabilistic
state of X in general, at least from our point of view.
The probabilities no longer
have any significance because we now know what
the classical state of X is.
It's a, and there's no longer
any uncertainty about this.
So we would now say this
that the probability that the system is in the state a is one.
We know this because we just looked at it and we saw that the classical state is a, so the new probabilistic state of X is one
in which the probability of
being in the classical state a is equal to one.
And that probabilistic state is represented by the
probability vector ket a.
We have a one in the entry corresponding to the classical state a and a zero in all other entries.
For example, if we again
consider the situation where X is a bit and we have the same
probabilistic state as before,
then if we measure X, we can imagine that a
transition takes place.
With probability three quarters, we see the classical state zero, and by measuring, we transition to ket zero
being our probabilistic state,
and with probability one quarter, we transition to ket one.
You can think about this as a transition of knowledge if you prefer as opposed to an actual
physical transition,
but what's important for
the sake of this lesson is to recognize how the mathematics works.
It's kind of trivial actually, but by recognizing this triviality, the analogous description
for the quantum setting
might seem a little bit less mysterious.
One final note is that to another person who didn't happen to see what
the classical state of X was when we measured it,
the probabilistic state
naturally wouldn't change as a result of us having measured it.
That's okay. Different individuals can
have different knowledge of a particular system and correspondingly choose
different probabilistic states
to represent their
knowledge of that system.
In the last part of this discussion of classical information, we'll talk about classical operations that can be performed on a system,
starting with deterministic operations.
When we perform an operation on a system, its state generally changes as a result, and in this context, the word deterministic means
that the result of performing
the operation depends entirely on whatever classical
state the system was in
prior to the operation being performed.
In other words, there's
no element of chance when a deterministic
operation is performed, so there's no randomness
or uncertainty involved.
In mathematical terms, deterministic operations
are described by functions.
Every function f of the form
that you see right here, which means that both the input and the output of the function
correspond to elements of
our classical state set sigma describes a deterministic operation.
The classical state a is
transformed into the state f of a for each choice of a state a.
For every function f of this form, there will always be a unique matrix M satisfying this condition
that you see right here,
and that is that by multiplying
M to the vector ket a gives us the vector ket f of a,
and that's true for every
choice of a classical state a.
It's not too hard to write down
an explicit description of M given whatever function f
of this form we've chosen.
It will always have exactly
one, one in each column with every other entry equal to zero.
And here's the formula. The b, a entry of M is equal to one if b is equal to f of a
and otherwise, it's equal to zero, and by this, we mean
this is the entry of M whose row corresponds to b
and whose column corresponds to a.